You know, Ross, we were talking in the last segment
about news that you can learn on Instagram.
Yeah, and you learned something, right?
I learned a ton of stuff.
A lot of people get their news on Twitter,
different platforms.
I love Instagram for a multitude of reasons
but I learned that the incredible artist, David Hockney,
is bringing his latest piece of optimism art
to the public in this super innovative way.
Okay. He's created this beautiful, hopeful
digital animation of a bright sunrise,
and it will be played on huge billboards in cities
around the world.
And it just is a really fun seamless way
to weave art into our every day lives.
And this is what I love about
some of the possibilities that may come out
of what the last year has brought us.
Would this have happened without the pandemic
and museums closing.
Would people say how do we experience art,
and listen, going to art museums is not for everybody.
And some people think it's kind of bougie
or maybe I'm not into this or you know that.
And also why is an art museum so precious?
Why do you have to pay and go in
and make this whole ceremony about it?
I see the argument on both sides.
I am a museum goer.
I am an art obsessed person.
I've traveled the world going to museums.
But what I love about this is the lack of preciousness.
The lack of like, you have to do it this way.
This is all about accessibility.
That's it.
Free, it doesn't cost anything.
It's just creating beauty.
I'm just, I'm excited.
I hope more things come about in the world like this.
And I think it is because of what we've been through.
People have been forced to be innovative
and you talk about accessibility.
That's what this is.
I grew up in a farm town,
never going to museums.
I always felt it was for like fancy people.
It wasn't until I was like 40
that I really went to a museum and thought,
oh my God, this is amazing.
And so people literally walking down the street,
not knowing they're going to be exposed
to this incredible art will look up
and maybe they'll realize that art is for them.
This to me is just a gift.
Awesome and it's all over the world.
I love that.
Love it.
(upbeat music)